for more on North Korea we're joined by
Jamie Metzl a senior fellow at the
Atlantic Council Jamie good morning good
morning
we just heard of the reporting there the
president had a conversation with
President Xi Jinping yesterday what can
we actually expect from China well I
don't know if we can expect much because
the United States policy is so chaotic
and so unfocused and under the Trump
administration the United States has
given up so much of the leverage that we
once had through things like jettisoning
the TPP and undermining our alliances
and just this sense that we are moving
in so many different directions it's
hard to know what to expect but China
has real reasons to be concerned about
what's what's happening not just because
the level of rhetoric is getting so high
and the tensions are increasing but also
there's a cost to China of this.d stable
destabilizing North North Korea and so
for the Chinese what they I hope will
come to understand is that this kind of
nuclear armed and hostile North Korea
harms their interests and if we can help
them get there then that would be
helpful for us Jamie we did learn Friday
that there are some diplomatic back
channels that have been essentially in
effect for a few months now how
effective do we think they are probably
not very effective there are very often
some kinds of diplomatic contacts even
with the North Koreans and these are
happening through New York a lot of it
has to do with these Americans who are
being held in in North Korea but even
with that we've seen a rapid
deterioration of the already terrible
relations between the United States and
North Korea such as such as they are so
I wouldn't put too much hope into that
as being meaningful in any way we heard
from Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
and he talked about this combined
message Trump was sort of the force and
the idea of diplomacy that that's
necessary to get North Korea to move at
all is that accurate I would feel so
great if I could discern any kind of
coherent strategy coming out of this
administration from what I see people at
lower levels are trying to put together
a strategy and then the president
seemingly on a whim will say some kind
of crazy thing and then everyone will
scramble to say oh we're doing good
cop/bad cop where's something else sort
of responding and saying
backing up the president yes Justin that
he needs to well if when the president
says these things in every if they say
oh my god we have no idea what he's
saying like yesterday he said that we're
preparing military options for Venezuela
and no one else in the government is
preparing military options for invading
Venezuela so then what do you do if you
have everyday the people in the
administration think we don't even know
what what the president is talking about
what what does that say and that touches
a bigger problem that we're facing here
that everyone is looking because we
expect some kind of strategy some kind
of coherence to come out of the White
House but the the the underlying just
stability and mental state of the
president could be an issue that is
maybe even bigger and broader than North
Korea alright Jamie Mitchell thank you
so much for being with us this morning